[Music]  picking off e t--'s kardashian ketchup  Kendall Jenner's nipples  that's so weird to me well sort of the  Victoria's Secret model is no stranger  to showing off a bit of skin she posted  this pic to snapchat on Saturday rocking  a sheer top with star pasties Kylie also  took to social media to post a trio of  sexy snaps flaunting her toned bod in a  long sleeve crop top and matching undies  on Instagram their big sis Khloe  Kardashian enjoyed a wine and snapchat  filled date night out with her NBA pro  boyfriend Tristan Thompson  while Courtney spent her rainy day  Friday baking with her daughter Penelope  and niece Northwest we're all in a good  place  Rob Kardashian's fiance and baby mama  blac chyna shared an update on her  weight loss she's lost 34 pounds since  giving birth to their daughter dream in  November  [Music]  you